mafia three is going mobile
I'm Lucien welcome to your cellular
GameSpot news update mafia three rivals
will launch our iOS and Android devices
on October 7th the same day that the
console and PC Edition comes out
according to the announcement from 2k
rivals is set in the same setting New
Orleans well it's actually called new
Bordeaux in the game but it's played
from a whole new perspective the game's
characters locations and events are
based on those in developer hangar 13 S
mafia 3 but the mobile game is more of
an RPG 2k explains begin your life of
crime squaring off against rival gangs
in battle RPG combat recruit and train
40 crime bosses from the Mafia 3
universe as they join your crew and
destroy any foes getting in the way
outfit new Bordeaux's newest hit squad
with an assortment of deadly weaponry
and other gear join up with friends and
battle players worldwide to see who has
the deadliest crew in new Bordeaux you
put your name down at the rivals website
to receive unspecified
in-game bonuses the game has been
developed by cat daddy which worked with
2k in the past for evolved NBA 2k and
WWE 2k the mobile games so what kind of
new perspective do you think will be in
mafia 3 rivals let me know in the
comments below I'll come find me on
Twitter I met Lucy games games for more
on Matthew 3 make she bit GameSpot